Asylum Seekers who've risked their lives
crossing the channel in small boats have
overwhelmed the system ill-equipped to
process them
now there are concerns that outbreaks of
infectious disease at the overcrowded
Reception Center at manston in Kent
could be repeated across the country as
the home office races to find hotel
accommodation the UK Health security
agency has declared a national incident
and in a memo seen by Sky News it warns
confirmed infections associated with
Asylum Seeker accommodation over the
past year have included diphtheria
shigella group a strep MRSA varicella
zoster kovid flu scabies and TB
it is not impossible to rule out
Transmission in the initial reception
centers and there is very limited
information regarding onward
transmission of infection
the risks to the general UK public of
acquiring infection as a result of this
incident is currently considered to be
very low Sky News understands Public
Health officials have identified cases
of infectious disease in Asylum Seeker
accommodation in Swindon Hertfordshire
Kent Birmingham greater Manchester and
Sheffield it's an absolute outrage that
at cases of diphtheria scabies
potentially other infectious diseases
are now popping up in places all around
the country because the home office has
failed to get a grip on the situation in
manston and it's failed to act on the
warnings from local authorities and MPS
that a situation like this was going to
occur the warning comes as local
authorities consider taking legal action
to prevent Asylum Seekers from being
placed in hotels authorities in East
Riding tried and failed to get an
injunction on Friday reflecting public
hostility we don't know who they are and
there could be criminals there could be
um
I think people are very caring and they
understand but I just don't think again
that's the right place
the home office says it's working with
health agencies to identify and treat
those with disease and ensure hotels can
isolate them but it all adds to the
pressure on an Under Fire Home Secretary
despite repeated promises the government
has failed to get to grips with the
challenge of Small Boat Crossings but
they are confident here of striking a
deal with the French authorities
possibly as soon as Monday to increase
patrols on the Normandy coast and cut
the number of Crossings
the government has also sought to deter
albanians who make up 40 of recent small
boat Travelers in London their
compatriots gathered to reject
stereotyping and scapegoating we are
here today to say to the thrillable man
we're not criminals who are normal
people like everyone I haven't risked my
life for a better life I've got 25 years
I've worked in this country I pay tax I
went to Thailand I came as a minor never
never claim benefit a plea for
compassion and easy to make harder for
many to heed in the absence of practical
Solutions pull Kelso Sky News